Hey guys, get ready to get your socks knocked right back onto your feet. I don't think that's a saying, and if that's your attempt at an intro, we just lost half the audience. Will your turn? Get ready to get your socks knocked back onto your feet, because that'd be a hell of a podcast. What were you thinking about? Come on.
Were you trying to do an intro? Yeah, that was good. It's because I reversed that. Hey there. Get ready to get your socks knocked back on. Hey, get ready to get your hair blown back onto your hips. Like what? This is going to unblow your mind, right?
This is going to tighten your socks and lace up on your shoes. God damn it. Just say, welcome to SmartLess. Welcome to SmartLess. Hey, welcome everybody. Hey guys, hey, how excited are you? I will. Have you ever had apple juice and ice like this?
It tastes really delicious. Is that what you washed down your egg salad with? Yeah, a little bit. I had a little bit of eggs today and a bagel with cream cheese. Wait, wait, wait, wait. If we turned you inside out, will we just see a big American flag? Yeah, absolutely. Don't bless your heart.
Sean, so what did you start with today? You started with the bagel? What? I did half of the bagel. A full bagel. A full bagel. Half is cream cheese, half is butter. Okay.
But it's plain. It's plain, right? Make no doubt. It's a plain bagel? It's a plain bagel. Do you ever try to save the time, because you've got to slice it and put it. Just take a bite of the bagel and then just a big sliver of cream cheese. And put it both ways.
Eat that and then some butter, just straight down the hatch. It'd be faster, that's for sure. Right, because you're wasting a lot of time, it seems like. But you're a plain bagel eater. I don't know any of you. Well, why? Why are you? You're going to put stuff on it.
Why have it in there? That's like just eating straight white bread. Most people go for some kind of a flavor. No, you put the flavor in the sandwich. But have you not tried an onion bagel, sesame bagel, poppy seed bagel, everything bagel? No. No, but have you ever tried it? No, I can smell it, so then therefore I've tried it.
You've never tried it? No, I've only eaten plain bagels. I mean, it's undeniably better than just a flat tasting piece of round white bread. Okay, look, I'll try it. I'm open to it. You're 52 years old. At least. I know.
The thing I'd like to get you in on is this torture that Will has dropped me into this torture chamber that Sam Jones, our friend who directed the behind the scenes tour thing of Smart List. The special that's coming out. Yeah. Yeah. And then also one of our guests, Matt Damon, is also involved in the torture chamber. So it's kind of a smart list torture chamber.
Oh, you're talking about portal? And the only person missing is you and also Scott. I'll do it. We're doing this. Yeah. We do the wordal, quartal and octordal every morning. Yeah. And then we have to do an aggregate score and it's torturous.
Well, I have an issue with the octordal people. And listener, this is the eight puzzles. But they think of these like we get it. You're bright. You come up with these words that no one's ever heard of, but that's a hat on a hat. It's already difficult to figure out the eight words. We don't need to also figure out words in a basically a different language. Can I just say something, man?
It's hard to figure out the five letter word. Can I just say something, Jason? Good for you, man. Good for you for standing up. I need to finally speak out. I've been afraid to speak out because I don't want blowback. Hey, have you guys ever played Mafia? Remember I talked about Mafia like a year ago?
It's not a word game. Are you just doing loose association of ideas? No. I'm dead. Us finishing talking is not your cue to come up with a different subject. No, I was telling you what I was doing last night. Speaking of. We played Mafia because you guys were talking about games.
Our guest today, guys, you see that? Well, we're just going to get right into it. Are you tired of talking? Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, no, no. But it's just this person. They didn't even say like, hello. Because this man is a director.
What? And there are very few. Jason, I love bringing directors in for you because I just, you get all giddy and all. I just got nervous. I asked him how he sets up shots and how he lights certain angles. And he's not just a director. He's a director of some of the biggest comedies and the biggest films of all time. Incredible blockbusters.
And also has produced some of the biggest, if not arguably the biggest now television show. Certainly in Netflix history. Question mark. Question mark. This is somebody who's Canadian. This is somebody showing that Jason, you've worked with. Talk about nice hair. Hairy toes.
Great hair. I can't wait to see the outfit. There's this little giggle. I'm ready. All right. How about this guy? How about this guy? Hi, guys.
Are you in, it looks like you're in a sort of an economical hotel. It's just a Hungarian hotel. Are you in a hotel? I'm in a hotel room where I have lived for four and a half months in Budapest, which is the longest I've ever been on location and the furthest that I've ever been on location and probably the last time that I will go this far away for this long. But hi, friends. Hi, Sean.
Why are you there? Oh, you're lucky listeners. This is a good man. Yeah, this is great. Talk in. I can't wait to talk about Stranger Things. I can't wait to talk about all the movies. This is so exciting.
But Sean, I feel like there's no way we can let go today without, I feel like we at a moment, apparently in a casting session of a night of museum. Because yes, I've listened to every episode. That's right. I've already gotten into Bateman's anti-turtle neck manifesto, but I handle that off air. But yeah, you're one of the three people that can pull it off. Yeah. Well, to remind the viewers, or the viewers, the listeners that I auditioned for one of
the night of the museum's movies. Which part? And you were so kind to call me in. Which part? And it was for Napoleon, I think. Oh, huh. Yeah. And then Walk got that part, didn't he?
Who did? Walkine. It's just an inside joke. He just wrapped it. He just wrapped it. Oh, that's right. He played Napoleon. He's playing Napoleon.
Really, Scott. Yeah. Pushing away. Went a different way with it. I went in with a bunch of ideas and like a dickwad and you were like looking at me like, uh-huh, maybe you can direct it too. Oh, really? No, but I feel like, no.
So, yeah. Sean, did you come with that line? I think I might have, according to Sean Hayes, Sean Levy, a young Sean Levy said, oh, did you want to direct it too? But here's the thing, Sean, you don't know me that well. I don't do dry. Sean, you don't play dry. So I think I was going, that's like an Arnett move.
That's a Bateman fucking superpower. But as you know, and as you can probably tell already, I don't do dry very well. It did make me chuckle. But I think I'm not sure the humor came across because I was off tone. And now I've learned to stay in my lane. I like to be obvious with my humor. But while we're overseas though, let's get back to hungry. What are you doing in Hungary?
And you've been there four and a half months. I'll bet it's something fabulous. Let's hear it. It is something fabulous. And so that is kind of what gets me through it. I am doing, there was a book, I don't know if any of you read it, called All the Light We Cannot See. I don't know.
We just finished it. And this book came out, for real? No. See? I don't do dry. That's a callback. Also used in comedy. Sean Levy, just so you know, if you ever reference a book again, neither of them has read a book
in years. I read, by the way, I read three this week. Go ahead. Okay. Well, there was a book. There was a book called All the Light We Cannot See. It won the Pulitzer Prize and it was the best seller like seven years ago. And they were going to do it as a movie and I couldn't even get a meeting on it.
And then I kind of waited and waited because I'm all about the long-term goals. And I found out about three years ago that the rights were available and I chased it and I said to the novelist, what if we do it as a limited series? Because that is such, you know, in the seven years and you get all your book in there. It's exactly right. And so then I decided to direct all of the episodes myself. So I am here. It's intense.
Wow. How many episodes? There's, it's only four episodes, but it's like a 90 day shoot, which is even the, even my biggest movies are 70 day shoots. What's that? What's the elevator pitch? Like, what's it about? It's World War II.
It's a blind French girl and her father who are running from the Nazi invasion in France and they're living in a coastal city in France. Her dad is Mark Ruffalo. Her uncle is Hugh Laurie and I cast, I decided I wanted to do this with an actress who was actually blind. Oh, wow. So we did a global search and we found this, this young woman named Aria Liberte who has never even auditioned for a part and she is legally blind.
And as you can imagine, it has been unlike any shoot that I've ever done. Now, Sean, not to get into a leavey, not to get into the weeds, but so when you have a legally blind actor, what do you do about like, if you have a real specific mark that an actor needs to hit because of technical issues with a dolly move or light or something like that? Like, how do you get around that? Well, very often what we do is you put a little piece of rope on sandbags, sandbag is a tripping hazard.
I've learned that the hard way. So you literally put a little piece of twine underneath tape and the truth is when you don't have sight, you're all your other senses you use so intensely, including touch and use your feet as other things that can feel. So she finds her mark with her feet. She, when she asks where the camera is, she's asked us to, we literally will snap where the camera is because she uses sound to echo, locate and map the room. That's fascinating.
Every day is fascinating. We have this kind of 20-something playing the grown-up version of this character, Marie, and we have this seven-year-old who is also blind named Nell, who we found in a small town in Wales and she is playing the younger version. And so you've got these experienced people like Ruffalo and Hugh Laurie and, you know, it's this big epic World War II kind of drama. How is the young woman playing the blind character? She is in her mid-twenties and the younger is now seven.
So that's got to be wild for somebody in their mid-twenties, not only just an actress with sight, but an actress without sight, learning the ropes of camera, blocking, lighting, like cues, and just all of that. It's fascinating. Well, we've all had visitors come to a set at some point and you see that people don't understand this strange workplace that is not like any kind of normal workplace. So she's got that, but she's also, she's never even acted. She never even was aspiring to act.
She found out about this search from a teacher she had when she was 11 and she sent in an iPhone video out of hundreds and she made it round after round after round after round and then she got the part. Well, let me ask you this, because this makes sense. She obviously, she's never seen a film or a television program by virtue of her not having the power of sight. But has she? Thanks for putting that together, Will.
Yeah, but well, I was going to say, well, no, I mean, sometimes you got to connect the dots for me. No, now I'm with you, Will. Obviously, it stands to reason, but I was going to say, is she aware of this? Yes, what I was asking, has she heard a lot of that stuff? Is she in touch with stuff in that way? Very much. Yeah.
Like she's seen every Marvel movie. She came into this. She had, I did a movie two years ago called Free Guy that she'd seen a bunch of times. She knows stranger things. So she is very steeped in pop culture, but she's not watching it. She is, she is using audio description and she loves it, but it's just in a different way. So that's how I watch Ozark with my eyes closed.
Same thing. And so an act, well, at least I'll speak for myself. I watch what I do and learn how to be better by noticing the things that I don't do well. If I didn't have my eyes, I wouldn't be able to see that. So how does one become a good actor if you've never seen not only what good actors do, but how you look when you feel an emotion, how knowing how that comes across, how you're able to. And that's the crux of it.
That's literally, we go through this almost every day where she'll play a scene and she might play it great, but maybe she's doing stuff with their face that is too busy. And she doesn't see herself or other actors. And she's never seen a smile. She's never seen different versions of a smile. And she's not seen herself in a mirror. So it is profound every day. And so what I, what she's learned is, oh, okay, understand where the camera is.
Like we've all learned, calibrate what you're doing based on the size of your face on that screen. And the size of the lens. And she'll ask is, and I've taught her like, like mini film school book and like the some medium shot. I'm at your waist. Then we're going to move the camera and suddenly it's more head to toe so you can be a little freer.
But what I've learned also, I mean, I've directed 13 movies now and I hadn't, and Jason, I've directed you obviously, but like, I use my face to direct so much. So like, I might say cut, Jason, let's, and I'll make a face, right? And I'll indicate what I want in the next day. I got that one a lot from you. That was listener. That was a, that was a not so much face. I got that from, from Sean a lot like, Hey, great, Jason, but it's kind of, it's, it's
suggesting 180 degrees, like the absolute opposite of whatever you're doing. Can we just flip it or, or we have that. We have that. No, I prefer this. We got that one. We got that version. That's high eyebrows. We have that.
Thank you. That's high eyebrows. And I'll do this hand gesture. Like when Kobe used to make a shot and run back to play D and he do this settled down hand. Just the settle. Yeah. Yeah.
And so some of that would just go to, I'm like, Hey, Jason, Jason, and I would just kind of like push my palms downward to, to stuff down. This is a dramatic scene. Yeah. Easy on the comedy. Now, Sean, is it because of like, you know, Canadians are known for just being the nicest people in the world, but you have this energy about you because we had a breakfast like decades ago and you were so charming and so funny and so witty.
And you, you have this infectious joy, joyous energy. I'm sure I'm not the only person ever say that that you must so good to be around. Yeah. That, that just must create this atmosphere on set. It's just a statement. I have no question. I just, I just find you incredibly joyful. It's real too.
It's, you know, you go, you don't, you don't know how somebody, how somebody really is until you, until you either play around a golf with them or you work a long schedule on a movie because you can't hide in those situations. I guess my question to that is what, when you're filmmaking, what really gets under your skin because I can't see you throwing a fit or getting angry. Well, it's funny because a mutual friend of a bunch of ours, I heard Ryan Reynolds to your show and I've now done two movies in a row with Ryan and his favorite thing, thank you.
His favorite thing is when he's like, Oh, Sean, Sean, he's going dark, Sean, he's going dark. And the truth is my version, well, you probably have Jace, but it's like, maybe the extent of his like, guys, we got to go. We got, why are we not shooting? But I just get more absurd. My voice gets a little screechy and I use my hands even more so, but you know, I think, I mean, I know a little bit about your backstory, Sean, because I've listened to smart lists
and I just, like my mom, she liked the bottle and it was not always an easy childhood. And I just, I feel like I just willed myself towards happiness, like I'm not going to have a sad life. I'm going to have a happy life and I want the things I make to put that in the world. Was dad around growing up or? He was around and I would go over, you know, like for two days a week. And then when I was 13, I moved in with him and my stepmom and that family full time because I just, I needed to kind of be safe.
Was this a Montreal, Sean? Yeah. Yeah. It was a Montreal. So your parents were split from when you were very, very, very young? Yeah. From the time I was three. Oh, wow.
And I didn't, it's weird because I didn't even, I never even talk about that stuff because A, who cares and B, some sense of privacy. But now that I'm, you know, in the middle part of my life, I see like everyone's like, I'm doing a drama now, right? I've done a lot of comedies and, but what I've, what I've found is I just want to take feeling and put it on screen. And plus you're like an incredible dad too with incredible daughters and incredible life and like.
I've had a lot of practice. I have four daughters. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So you have four, how old are your daughters? They are 22 down to 11, so 22, 20, 15, 11. So it's, and a wife of 28 years.
And so it's, I mean, it says it all, are they with you in Hungary? They're not with you in Hungary. Actually, you know what? They, they, they mostly not been, but they were here until a few hours ago. And literally my wife's parting words to me when I dropped out for the airport is she's like, don't push it on smart lists. Yeah. She literally, she knows that the more I love something, and this circles back to your question
about like on set, I do tend to be pretty energetic because I love being there. I love your show. I've never, I told your producers like, I don't do, I can't think of doing press with something I love. And I've listened to pretty much every episode and it feels so authentic and funny as shit. And I'm really thrilled to be here. It's such a fit right in. Well, that's very kind of you to say, we're surprised always.
I was telling my buddy Todd and down in St. Bart's good friend of mine. We're always surprised that, that people listen to, to the show. So thank you. I will say, I want to ask you a little bit about, so you're in Montreal and how does a guy from Montreal go on to direct huge movies and be like Sean Levy for Tracy? Let's just write a lot. I know. Cause I feel like Tracy and many of your listeners like, who is this?
No. And that's okay. Cause here's one of the things, when I start to describe who it is and I start listing off your credits, then I know that immediately Bateman and Hayes are going to get it really quickly. So I'm trying to do it. So you directed 13 films, some of which are all the night of the museum movies. Yeah.
Did you direct cheaper by the dozen? I did. Yeah. Free guy. You did. The reason one was called the Adam project. You also directed stranger things. Stranger things is the, the weird, it started with a conversation with you, Jason, cause
we did a movie called this is where I leave you. And in my experience, when, when you think you're making the thing that's going to change everything, it ain't the thing that's going to change everything. Right. So true. Right. So like, cause I was the family comedy guy and I done like pink panther and she by the dozen and date night and night museum.
And I found this book called this is where I leave you and I chased it for five years and I got the cast of my dreams. It's Jason with Adam driver and Jane Fonda and Ben Schwartz and Catherine Hawn and Tina Faye. It was ridiculous. It was like a murder's row every day in the little house, Corey Stoll and no one went to their trailer. We stayed in the house and we, we just, we shot 28 days and it was great.
And then it didn't do very well. And I then had to do a panel and Jason was the moderator and I was, I was hurting cause when you fail in this job, it's public and it hurts and all of us have felt it. And I was like, Jason, I don't know if I can kind of like turn it on tonight. And he said, he goes, Hey, we made someone's favorite movie. Might be one persons, might be a couple of dozen, but this movie, the people who are seeing it and who it resonates for, they're going to hold onto it. And it was this revolution.
You don't even remember this conversation, Jason, but it was, I had lived and died by the sword of box office for so long. There was one metric of success, what's your opening weekend? What's your worldwide growth, right? And I made those kinds of movies and I had a good run, but that was the beginning of, wait, maybe there's other measurements of why you do things. And there's other movies that don't lend themselves to popcorn box office, you know? And there are plenty of movies that you know in the history of the cinema, if I can borrow
that term from a bunch of young actors who have no reason or right to use it, give me a fucking break. It's like, I hear a guy going, in the cinema, I'm like, you grew up in a fucking trailer in Florida, shut the fuck up. But there have been a lot of, you know, there are a lot of, I guess my point is this, Sean, if you're ever trying to figure out how to deal with getting kicked in the nuts and show business and how do you deal with it, just call me, man, because I've got tons of experience. It's almost all I've had, and I always joke that if it wasn't for bad movies, I wouldn't
have made any at all. So if you ever want to make yourself feel better, ever, just fucking call me. And you just go, oh, I'm a fucking success, what am I talking about? I just talked to Ernette, what a loser. Wait, Sean, can I ask, because you couldn't tell by his tan, though. The guy looks like a trillion dollars. You got Paul Anka type of tan going right now. Thank you.
Another great Canadian. Yeah, that's deep. But I need to fan out. But so wait, hang on, we never answered this. So you've got me. But Sean, are you going to remember your question or shit you want to ask? Yes, I'll remember. I was just going to say that at the end of that year, 2014, that happened.
I made the last night museum movie, and then Robin Williams, with whom I'd made three movies over 10 years, died. And I was just knocked out. And I said at that point, like, I'm going to say no for a while and see what happens. I'm going to have, because I've done a movie a year for a decade, and in that breath came a rival. Yes. What are my favorite movies in all time?
And in that same moment came Stranger Things. And those things changed everything and have changed everything since. I was going to mention, those are the two, I mean, Arrival's one of my favorite movies of all time. I've seen it like 10 times. I mean, have you guys seen it? Yeah, I've seen Arrival. But I want to get back to Sean, before we get into that, I want to get back to right
that moment you were just saying, that that moment changed your life. It was a shift of perspective that you had. Yes. Right? And once you were able to kind of get out, as you said, stop chasing this thing. Stop looking for that. Stop looking to measure your own success. We've talked about this based on what you do or how you do in the box office.
But more, I'm going to say no, because I'm going to find something, because I don't know anymore. And in a certain way, you just kind of, it's that ability to just let go and surrender to the process and just go, fuck it, I don't know. And also just to, like, why did you guys start Smart List? Because as near as I can figure, you wanted to see what it was like, right? The pandemic was happening and who knows if this will be something. I remember texting with Jason early on, no one knew if it would become something.
You did it because you wanted to and it seemed like it would be fun and interesting. Right here, yeah. The same thing, Stranger Things, no one wanted that show. I wasn't even in the TV business. I'm a movie director and these boys, these duffers came in with the best script I'd ever read and I literally brought them into my office and I said, I don't know what's going to happen if anyone will watch it, but I definitely want to help you get it made. I'm sure I'm not the last or the first person to say this, but it gave me a lot of my childhood
back. It was like, that's exactly how I live. Hopefully you're the last to say that, I mean, I know you're not the first, but I would ride my bike to my friend's house, we'd play Dungeons and Dragons and it was like, so cool. But so Sean, it was just another example of how keen your eye is for stuff that is going to be appealing for many, many, many people in addition to the fancy folks, because the fancy folks love all the commercial movies that you've done, including Stranger Things, but these things all get great reviews too.
So what is it about, we can just take Stranger Things for an example, you said you're not sure if people are going to watch it, but you definitely saw something of value there to push forward and want to champion it. So what was it about that show and your eye in general that can find the populist thing that also is married to kind of the sophisticated thing? Well, I think the populist thing is if it has a theme that I think everybody wrestles with, that's what I say yes. So Stranger Things, yeah, it was about a missing kid in another dimension, a monster, but it's
really an anthem to outcast. That is about the AV club, the people who don't fit in, who find each other and their connection is their superpower. That's everybody, every human has felt at points, whether as kids or teens or as adults, like, wait, where is my place in this constellation of people for whom life seems so much fucking easier? And when I just have a feeling that a lot of people can relate to an idea, to a theme, those are the ones they said yes to, like I said no to Free Guy five years ago when
I read it as a script, but when Ryan read it and called me over and said, look, I'm not a big gamer either, but it's about someone who feels helpless in their world. It's about an actual literal background character living in a world that is shitty and they feel powerless in it and considers that maybe they can do something in it. That's the theme of Free Guy. That's why I did Free Guy. The gaming stuff helps sell it, but it's not why we made it. So I'm always looking for theme, and that's what it was on Stranger Things.
I love that. Such a great success story. It changed so much. It came along at the right time. Where is Stranger Things now? It's second to last season, question mark? Yes. In fact, by the time people are listening to this conversation, we will have launched
volume two of our fourth season. So we launched seven episodes called volume one, and we're doing only one more season. You're going to do another season after this one? Yes. We are doing season five, and that will be the last. Wow. That's super cool. Are you going to get in there and direct any of those?
Always. Always. Every season you have. Correct. Every season I have directed episode three and four, and some of it is superstition. But it started off, the idea when we sold it to Netflix was the Duffers wanted to direct all of them. And they were directing the first few episodes, and it became clear that they were never
going to finish writing the season. So I basically said, I'll come to Atlanta where we film, and I'll do a couple of episodes, go hibernate with the script. So I came in, and I ended up doing episodes that, you know, the Christmas lights episode in season one. Yeah, yeah. There are moments that, I mean, I've never directed horror, but what I love about the job, it's probably what you do too, Jason, which is, okay, what tone does this story
want? Yeah. Right? There's some directors like Wes Anderson or Baz Lerman, where their stamp is the same on everything they make. Right. That's not the kind of director I am. I'm going to change, the free guy looks different than the Atom Project.
Right. Looks different than Night of the Museum. So I'm always, and I learn new visual muscles, or I gain more visual muscles on stranger things, and ever since then, two episodes a season, and that'll be the same thing next year. That's so cool. So cool. It's that Spielbergian type of cinematic approach that, you know, your stuff has always
对。看起来跟《博物馆奇妙夜》完全不同。所以我一直在《怪奇物语》中锻炼新的视觉肌肉，或者说获取更多视觉肌肉，从那以后，每季拍两集，明年也是这样。太酷了。太酷了。这就是那种斯皮尔伯格式的电影质感，你知道的，你的作品一直
looked great, but there's a muscularity to the way in which those duffers established kind of that cinematic heft. Well, do you know what it is? It's interesting, Sean was saying it brought back a certain period of his life, me too. The duffers were born in 84. So for me, I'm doing a nostalgia trip, right? But their show, what they're doing is the movies of the 80s that they watched on VHS in the 90s.
看起来很棒，但达菲兄弟确立这种电影厚重感的方式有一种力量感。嗯，你知道是怎么回事吗？很有意思，肖恩说这唤起了他人生中的某个时期，我也是。达菲兄弟是84年出生的。所以对我来说，我在进行一次怀旧之旅，对吧？但他们的节目，他们做的是他们90年代在录像带上看到的80年代电影。
That's right. That's the love letter they're doing. That's right. I'm doing a love letter to my high school years. So right. Right. And it's interesting that we have different access points, and now my stepmom who's in her mid-70s loves the show and so do my daughters.
没错。这就是他们写的情书。没错。我是在给我的高中时代写情书。所以对。对。有趣的是，我们有不同的切入点，现在我七十多岁的小妈也很喜欢这个节目，我的女儿们也是。
And that's the unicorn thing about Stranger Things is the demographic crossover. Let me ask you something about comedy, because, you know, obviously you're a pro in it. And what do you do when you get somebody on set that you, an actor, is there like a trick to you or some kind of exercise you do when you take a quote, non-funny person or like somebody who's not known in comedy and try to- This takes me to my question about Ryan Reynolds. You know, why do you keep working with them? He's just a scene killer.
这就是《怪奇物语》独一无二的地方，也就是跨越各个年龄段。我问你个关于喜剧的问题，因为，你知道的，显然你是这方面的专家。当剧组里来了一个演员，你该怎么办，有什么诀窍吗，或者当你试图把一个所谓的非搞笑人物，或者一个在喜剧界不出名的人，试着把——这让我想到了我关于瑞安·雷诺兹的问题。你知道的，你为什么一直跟他合作？他简直是个毁戏大王。
You just go into the editing room and you just go, okay, let's rework it. Yeah. I've had actors who you definitely go in the edit room. You're like, fuck, I got to save this one. I got to save it. But- But somebody who's not too strength isn't comedy. Oh, no, I've had it.
你只要走进剪辑室，然后就会说，好吧，我们重新来过。对。我遇到过一些演员，你走进剪辑室时肯定会想，操，我得救救这段。我得把它救回来。但是——但是如果某个人的强项不是喜剧。哦，不，我遇到过。
Like, look, I would love to be in this. Well, by the way, hey, you're pretty really nicely. There are some fucking people who are just not funny and you have to make them funny. Here's what I've learned, guys. I have learned this repeatedly and I so want to give you the famous names as examples because they're really famous in their phenomenal in their, in their own like lane. But here's what I know. You can get a great dramatic performance from a comedic genius of an actor.
比如，听着，我很想演这个。顺便说一句，嘿，你演得真的很不错。有些混蛋就是一点都不搞笑，你还得想方设法让他们变得搞笑。各位，这是我学到的。我一再学到这一点，我真想给你们举几个大名鼎鼎的名字作为例子，因为他们在自己的领域里真的非常有名，而且很了不起。但这是我所知道的。你可以从一个喜剧天才演员那里得到伟大的正剧表演。
We've all seen it. We've done it. We cannot make someone unfunny hear the music if they are tone deaf. And I've literally, there was an actor on Night Museum where I'm like, no, no, do you hear, like, take, take the pause. Like, buh buh buh buh buh buh. And then, and then that actor would go buh buh buh buh buh. No, no, listen to me.
我们都见过。我们也拍过。但如果一个人五音不全，无论如何也听不出音乐的节奏，我们就没办法让一个不好笑的人变好笑。我真的遇到过，在拍《博物馆奇妙夜》时有个演员，我当时就说，不，不，你听到了吗，就像，停顿一下。就像，哒哒哒哒哒哒。然后，然后那个演员就会哒哒哒哒哒。不，不，听我说。
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh. And it's literally on, on Free Guy. That's what you get. Jody Comer had never done comedy. And we got the name, guys. No, it's not Jody Comer because she ended up being great because she's really funny. She's really funny. But here's how she, for the first few days, she was like, Jane Fonda was on our movie
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。这在《失控玩家》里简直一模一样。你得到的就是这个。朱迪·科默以前从没演过喜剧。我们还猜过大牌呢，伙计们。不，不是朱迪·科默，因为她最后演得棒极了，因为她真的很有趣。她真的很有趣。但她是这样适应的，前几天她就像是，简·方达曾参演过我们的电影
This Where I Leave You where she's watching the funny swirl around her and she's like, where do I fucking get my boat in this river? Like it's, it's moving too fast. How do I get my boat in the water? And with Jody, with Jody Comer, I said, you're like an accent, Savant. I've seen killing Eve. You're like, your ear is insane. That's how you think about comedy.
《弗兰西丝·哈》或者是《留下的日子》，她看着喜剧元素在她周围流转，心想：我他妈该怎么把我的船划进这条河里？就像它，流动得太快了。我怎么把我的船放进水里？而对朱迪，对朱迪·科默，我说，你简直是个语言奇才。我看过《杀死伊芙》。你就像是，你的乐感太疯狂了。这就是你思考喜剧的方式。
It is, it is sound, it is inflection, it is rhythm. Hear the rhythm, hear the pitch. That's where you'll find the funny. And she's working with Ryan Reynolds and Taika Waititi and Utkarsh and Butkar who are all such Jedi masters at funny that she used her ear. So I'll usually, Sean, sometimes they cannot be saved and I'll cut around them. Or I just won't go to them for comedy. I'll literally go, you're the backboard.
它是，它是声音，它是语调，它是节奏。听节奏，听音高。那才是你找到笑点的地方。她跟瑞安·雷诺兹、塔伊加·维迪提、乌特卡什合作，乌特卡什他们都是喜剧界的绝地大师，所以她发挥了自己的乐感。所以我通常会，肖恩，有时他们实在没救了，我就绕过他们剪辑。或者我干脆不找他们演喜剧。我甚至会直接说，你就是个背景板。
Everyone just keeps shooting. This is the backboard. Their name is X. They happen to be in a scene with you. But I try to find some way. That's my career. That's my career. Funny, funny, funny.
所有人都在继续拍。这就是背景板碰巧跟你在一场戏里的那个演员，名字叫X。但我会试图找到某种方法。这就是我的职业生涯。这就是我的职业生涯。搞笑，搞笑，搞笑。
And then cut to Bateman for reaction. Leave you, leave you, slow down. Because Sean's writing all this down. He's trying to. He's not. It's not funny. So slow down. And he got the last bit, right?
然后切到巴特曼的反应镜头。等等，等等，慢点。因为肖恩正在把这些全记下来。他正努力呢。他才没有。一点都不好笑。所以慢点。他最后那句听清了吧，对吧？
And so just listen, Sean. All right. You just play it back for yourself later, Sean, when it's released. I love, you know, we always joke around. We talk about it sometimes, not even just in work, just in life. People who aren't necessarily that funny. And by the way, I'm not saying that we are the fucking end all, or we're particularly funny there.
所以听着就行，肖恩。好了。肖恩，等节目播出后，你自己回放着听吧。我喜欢，你知道的，我们总是开玩笑。有时我们甚至不只是在工作中谈论，在生活中也是。那些不一定那么搞笑的人。顺便说一句，我并不是说我们自己就是他妈的终极权威，或者我们特别搞笑。
You're extremely funny. I'll say it because you can't. You're super. No, but I will say that again, like there's always somebody funnier, but people who aren't necessarily funny, they come at you sometimes because they think like, oh, you guys rib each other. So they, all they do is they come at you really hard in a really weird way. And I was doing a tennis match once, a, one of these things that you were playing in the
你极其搞笑。我得说出来，因为你自己不好意思说。你超级——不，不过我要说的是，就像总有人比你更好笑一样，但那些不一定搞笑的人，他们有时会针对你，因为他们觉得，哦，你们俩经常互相开玩笑。所以他们这么做，只是用一种非常奇怪、非常生硬的方式来针对你。我以前打过一次网球比赛，一个，你们参加过的其中一场比赛
match. It was like a charity to raise money for the US Open and it was me and Farrell against a couple of guys. And one of the guys, this is a long time ago, so I feel confident, but maybe he'll know. And all he did was just come at Farrell so hard in this way that I kind of looked at him and I was like, geez, he's like, yeah, what the fuck, man, take your foot off the gas because they had that their instinct. And I have seen it at work before a couple of times too.
那是一场为美国网球公开赛筹款的慈善赛，我和法雷尔对阵另外两个家伙。其中一个家伙，这事是很久以前发生的了，所以我很有信心，不过也许他会认出来。他所做的一切就是用这种方式狠狠地针对法雷尔，以至于我看了他一眼，然后说，天哪，他就像是，是啊，搞什么鬼，老兄，脚下留情吧，因为他们有那种本能。我也在工作中见过好几次这种情况。
And it's really awkward. And you're like, man, just cool it. Just don't know. I had this somewhat recently where an actor was like, like, no, no, but I'm like, just stop trying. Just I'm begging you. Yeah. Stop trying.
这真的很尴尬。你会想，老兄，冷静点。就是别这样。我最近也遇到过类似的情况，有个演员表现得，就像，不，不，但我想说，别再刻意表现了。我求求你了。对。别再硬撑了。
This is not your thing. It's your youth. I think that's like young. That's how I was probably in that audition with you or probably in lots of auditions or whatever. You're just so young. You're just like, I got to try really hard. And you don't know.
这不适合你。这是因为你年轻。我想这就跟年轻一样。我可能当年跟你一起试镜时也是这样，或者在很多试镜里大概都这样，诸如此类。你当时就是太年轻了。你就会觉得，我必须拼命表现。而你当时什么都不懂。
Yeah. But Sean, your attitude is different there. You're actually trying to do something. You're not trying to, you're not doing out of fear. But you know what else it is, I think, and I talk about this with my daughters a lot. I think that at a certain point, we all want to have an idea of who we want to be, right? But we are each given certain gifts and we are lacking certain skills. And at a certain point in life, you have to look at what you are and you have to distinguish
是的。但肖恩，你的态度跟那不一样。你当时是真的在努力做一件事。你不是在尝试，你不是出于恐惧而做的。但你知道它还是什么吗，我想，我经常和我的女儿们谈论这个。我觉得在某个特定的人生阶段，我们都希望对“自己想成为什么样的人”有一个概念，对吧？但我们每个人都被赋予了某些天赋，同时也缺乏某些技能。在人生的某个阶段，你必须审视自己是什么样的人，并且必须把这一点
it from what you want to be. Because no one ever got to a happy life hitting their head against a wall if it's not dovetailing with the gifts they have. And I do feel that maybe this is like the best therapy, but it took me a lot of years. Like I remember after night at the museum, I wanted to do a dark drama. And I remember Chris Columbus, who was a producer at Night Museum, he said, why are you running from the thing that comes easily to you? Yeah.
与你想成为什么样的人区分开来。因为如果这与你拥有的天赋不吻合，没有人通过不断碰壁就能过上幸福的生活。我也觉得，也许这就像是最好的治疗，但这也花了我好多年。就像我记得拍完《博物馆奇妙夜》后，我想拍一部黑暗风格的正剧。我记得克里斯·哥伦布，他是《博物馆奇妙夜》的制片人，他说：你为什么要逃避那些对你来说轻而易举的事呢？是的。
Because it doesn't feel like you're doing anything. That's right. That's right. That's exactly right. But it's actually, you know, you've just identified the thing you're natural at. Enjoy. Yeah. But you know what, it's weird too.
因为这感觉不像是你在做什么有挑战的事。没错。没错。完全正确。但这实际上，你知道的，你刚刚发现了你天生擅长的领域。享受它吧。是的。但你知道吗，这也很奇怪。
I don't know if you guys feel the same way. I feel like this age, it's almost like within, you know, I'm 52, it's within the last two years. You don't look it, man. Thank you. You don't look it. You don't look it. But when that tan fades, I'm concerned.
我不知道你们是否有同感。我觉得到了这个年龄，几乎就像是，你知道的，我52岁了，就在这过去的两年里。你看起来可不像，老兄。谢谢你。你看起来不像。你真的不像。但当那个美黑褪色的时候，我就有点担心了。
You look 70. Yeah. You are. You are? I woke up this morning and I already felt like a fucking loser. But I think it was quite honestly, it was 50 that made me realize all these things and start to, and all these things, these hangups that I had, or these ideas, or the story that I would tell myself about myself, I just started to change it.
你看起来像70岁。是啊。真的吗？我今天早上醒来时，就觉得自己已经是个彻头彻尾的失败者了。但老实说，我想是50岁让我意识到了所有这些事情，并开始，所有这些我一直以来的心结，或者这些想法，或者我对自己讲述的关于我自己的故事，我开始改变它了。
And the things I was worried about or cared about, I don't care about anymore. I don't know. It is one of, I'm right at the, I'm 53, and it is definitely like, there's a lot that's shitty about midlife, but there are some things that are really fun. And the two that I found is acceptance, God willing, some fucking acceptance of what and who you are. And the other is I do find, Brian talks about this sometimes when we're on set, because like, we'll walk on and I can, I can block that scene and know my shots in about three
那些我曾经担心或在意的事情，我再也不在意了。不知道为什么。这绝对是其中之一，我正处于，我53岁了，中年确实有很多糟糕的地方，但也有一些真的很棒。我发现的两点是：承认知命，老天保佑，总算能接受自己是什么人、是谁了。另一点我发现，布莱恩在片场时有时也会谈到这一点，因为当我们走上片场时，我可以，我大概在三分钟内就能把那场戏的分镜头排好并清楚知道我要拍哪些镜头
minutes now. It did not come that easy and that smoothly a decade ago and you get a competence at your work as you get into midlife that is, I'm finding it enjoyable, like really enjoyable. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Your work ethic is just incredible. The amount of work you're able to put out and at a high level, do you think that's part of it now even more so that because you're so confident with what you're doing, you're
了。在十年前，事情可没这么简单、这么顺利。随着你步入中年，你会对自己的工作产生一种能力感，我发现这种感觉很享受，真的是非常享受。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你的职业工作道德简直不可思议。你能产出的工作量，而且还能保持高水平，你觉得现在更是如此吗？因为你对自己在做的事情如此自信，你对
so comfortable with what you're doing that you can take on so much because Sean, your output is just stunning. I mean, your company is just, just thriving. Do you feel, I bet you don't feel overwhelmed, I bet you don't feel like you're under servicing anything. I rarely do. I mean, the whole goal, especially once I had that like 2014, 2015 moment where I was like, oh, wait, I can't control outcomes.
自己在做的事情如此得心应手，所以你能承担这么多工作，因为肖恩，你的产出太惊人了。我的意思是，你的公司简直，简直蒸蒸日上。你觉得，我敢说你不会感到不知所措，我敢说你不会觉得自己有什么地方服务不到位。我很少会有这种感觉。我的意思是，整个目标，尤其是当我经历了2014年、2015年那个时刻，当时我心里想，哦，等等，我无法控制结果。
So I better stop living for it. I better stop living for box office as if I can control it. That was always a fable process. You cannot like, you don't know if your movie or show is going to do well. You do it because you believe in it and then you better goddamn well have fun while you're making it. Yeah. And enjoy the people that you've hired to work with.
所以我最好不要再为它而活。我最好不要再为了票房而活，好像我能控制它一样。那一直是一个虚幻的过程。你无法预知你的电影或节目是否会成功。你做它是因你相信它，然后在制作的过程中，你最好他妈的好好享受乐趣。是的。并享受你雇来合作的人。
Yes, and that's definitely, that's definitely where I've been at the last several years. I've had people look at me funnily when I, because I've sort of said something similar where I said like, if I'm going to do something that's going to take me away from my family and my kids, which is obviously that stuff becomes more and more into focus of like, of course, it's more important than anything else. So if I'm going to do it, it better be fun. And I have had people in a professional setting be like, look at me kind of strangely like, oh, that's important to you to have fun.
是的，这绝对是我过去几年一直在经历的状态。当我说出类似的话时，人们曾用异样的眼光看我——我说，如果我要做一件会让我离开家人和孩子的事情（显然，这些事情越来越成为关注的焦点，当然，它们比任何事情都重要），那么如果我要去做，它最好是有趣的。我在职业场合中遇到过有人用那种奇怪的眼光看着我，仿佛在说：“哦，觉得开心对你来说很重要啊。”
It's work. I'm like, no, no, no, no, no. We don't get another crack at this. This is it now. You're in it now. There is no, it's not like, and then I'll do this. And then I'll do the thing. And then I do it.
这是工作。我当时想，不，不，不，不，不。我们没有第二次机会了。就是现在。你现在已经身处其中了。没有那种，就好像，然后我会做这个。然后我会做那件事。然后我再做它。
No, no, it's now. It's now. Yeah, for sure. It's now. For sure. And what are you waiting for? Yeah, to do that. But Sean, to that point in everything you said earlier about just kind of reaching middle
好啦。当然是现在。毫无疑问。还在等什么呢？是的，去那样做。不过肖恩，说到这一点，还有你刚才谈到的关于刚好步入中
age and kind of figuring out who you are and staying in your lane or kind of veering off just ever so slightly, but still kind of staying in that on the same road, at least. Just looking at what you have coming up, you're like 17 things in production as a producer. Are you one of those personalities that has to have all of these things going, or are you reaching a point in your life where you're like, you know what, I have to find balance because that's what I'm kind of talking about a lot for myself. Balance about like, yes, to Jason's point, you have this company that's just massive and doing all of these things, but are you afraid of downtime?
年，然后摸清楚自己是谁，坚守自己的阵地，或者只是稍微偏离一点点，但至少还是留在那条路上。看看你接下来的项目，作为制片人，你有大约17个项目正在制作中。你是那种必须同时推进所有这些事情的性格，还是说你正处于人生的某个阶段，觉得，你知道吗，我必须找到平衡，因为这正是我经常为自己考虑的事情？关于平衡，就像，是的，正如杰森所说，你拥有一个如此庞大且在做所有这些事情的公司，但你害怕没有工作空闲吗？
Because I'm just reaching that point where I'm figuring out that balance. I used to be, I'm not anymore, this long location gig crystallized a lot for me. And I think we're making something special, but that's still five months that I missed of my daughter's life. And to your point, I mean, I think you put it so beautifully, like, it's happening right now. The thing that you're planning for and goal, you know, goal creed, like, it's it. This is happening.
因为我正处在那个阶段，我正在摸索那种平衡。我以前是，现在不是了。这次漫长的外景拍摄让我对很多事情有了清醒的认识。而且我认为我们正在创造一些特别的东西，但那仍然是我错过的女儿生活中的五个月。正如你所说，我的意思是，我觉得你表达得太美妙了，就像，这一切正在此时此刻发生。你一直在规划、设立目标的事情，就像，就是这样。这一切正在发生。
And this is all part of it. So, and that's the other, I don't know, Will, I think you have some kids who are maybe teens and I don't know, with the ages, Jase, I think years are a little young still. But that was a big part of that 2014, 2015 crucible moment where I, my oldest was in 11th grade, I think. And I was like, wait a second, they're not going to live with me forever. Like that was a revelation. Yeah.
而这也是其中的一部分。所以，这也是另一回事，我不知道，威尔，我想你们有些孩子可能已经是青少年了，我不知道他们的年龄，杰斯，我觉得你们的孩子可能还小一点。但那是2014年、2015年那个关键时刻的很大一部分，当时我，我的大女儿当时大概上11年级吧。然后我心想，等一下，他们不可能永远和我住在一起。这简直是一个启示。是的。
I somehow never thought about it with terror and the heartbreak of, oh, these years that we are a family together, they are finite and they end. And that changed things too. You know, this summer, so I'm out on the East coast in the summertime, because when I'm not in St. Bard's, I'm in East Hampton and I'm sorry, I'm just, I'm just sorry. You guys should know I'm going for douchebag of the year, so I'm trying to say as much as I can at once. I think you just locked it.
我不知怎么地从来没有带着恐惧和心碎去想过这一点，哦，我们作为一家人在一起的这些岁月，它们是有限的，终究会结束。这也改变了事情。你知道，今年夏天，所以夏天我在东海岸，因为我不在圣巴特斯的时候，我就在东汉普顿，对不起，我只是，我只是抱歉。你们应该知道我在争夺年度混蛋奖，所以我正试图一次性说尽可能多的话。我想你刚刚稳拿这个奖了。
You just locked it. I don't know. But, but no, actually, you know, when I drive a GMC pickup, I'm out here because I'm also kind of a contrarian. Well, is it professional grade? Because if it is, that would make sense. Obviously, it's professional grade. Yeah.
你刚刚稳拿了。不知道。但是，但是不，事实上，你知道，当我开着GMC皮卡时，我在这里是因为我也是个反叛者。好吧，这是专业级的吗？因为如果是的话，那就说得通了。显然是专业级的。是的。
And it's got the multi-pro tailgate, which was developed by GMC. Wow. What? Or professional grade. Sound just like the guy who does the commercial. But the point is this, so I'm out here and my son Archie, who's 13, he, he said to me like last week, he goes, hey, can I borrow your, he was like, I'm going to go work out. And I said, okay, which has become like kind of a new thing.
而且它还带有由GMC开发的多功能尾门。哇。什么？还是专业级。听起来就像拍广告的那个人。但重点是这样的，所以我在这里，我的儿子阿奇，他13岁，他，他上周对我说，嘿，我可以借你的，他当时说，我要去锻炼。我说，好吧，这已经成了某种新常态。
And he's like, hey, can I borrow your shoes? And I said, sure. And then he's 13 and he's wearing my size 12 shoes. And I don't know why that it felt like such a, like a bucket of cold water on my face. I was like, my baby is wearing my size 12 shoes. Wow. What? And I just wanted to hug him and like keep him small and just be like, oh, what the fuck?
然后他说，嘿，我能借你的鞋子吗？我说，当然可以。然后他13岁，竟然穿着我12码的鞋子。我不知道为什么这感觉像是一盆冷水当头泼下。我当时想，我的宝贝儿子竟然穿着我12码的鞋子。哇。什么？我只想拥抱他，让他一直那么小，然后忍不住想：卧槽，这算什么事？
Yeah. Yeah. It, starting at, at fifth grade, they actually start to be like, I'm not kind of good. I got, I got, I want to hang out with my friends this weekend. And like, and then when, of course, when they're 18, they're just gone. And then they come back once or twice a year if they like you for some holiday visits. But other than that, their, their next stop on the family run is with people they haven't even met yet.
是的。是的。从五年级开始，他们实际上就开始变成这样了，我不太好。我有，我有，我这个周末想和我的朋友们出去玩。而且，当然，等他们18岁时，他们就直接搬走了。然后他们一年回来一两次，如果他们喜欢你的话，回来过个节什么的。除此之外，他们在家庭这条路上的下一站，将是和那些他们甚至还不认识的人在一起。
And those are going to be their family. Yeah. That's great. And it's just like, I literally just put Franny on the plane this morning for camp in Europe for five weeks. Literally, I had to get up to look in on her because if she's probably close to where I am right now, I can pop over. I can hover if you want.
而那些人将成为他们的家人。是的。太棒了。就像，我今天早上刚把弗兰尼送上飞往欧洲参加五周夏令营的飞机。真的，我得去看看她，因为如果她离我现在的位置比较近的话，我可以顺便过去。如果你想的话，我可以在附近晃晃。
Yeah. If you're near Amsterdam, get over there. Oh, she had to go to Amsterdam first too. She kept saying I need to go to Amsterdam. Yeah. You got to, you got to fill up the backpack. And so, but I'm, I'm, I'm trying to train myself to, to be okay with, with kissing goodbye and enjoy life.
对。如果你在阿姆斯特丹，就过去看看。哦，她得先去阿姆斯特丹。她一直说我需要去阿姆斯特丹。对。你得，你得把背包填满。所以，但是，我，我，我正在努力训练自己，去接受离别，并享受生活。
Go ahead. You know, how was the goodbye though, Jay today was, I mean, was she excited to go? She was. She was awesome. She was very brave, very happy, you know, nervous, but, but on it, she's got coping skills. She, and that's the, that's the thing I think is all you can really hope for is to try to build them that, that healthy, you know, decision maker on top of their shoulders.
说吧。你知道，杰斯，今天的告别怎么样，我是说，她去的时候兴奋吗？她挺兴奋的。她太棒了。她非常勇敢，非常开心，你知道的，虽然紧张，但，但她应付得来，她有应对能力。她，这就是，我认为你真正能指望的全部，就是试着在他们的肩膀上，为他们建立起那种健康的、你知道的、能够自己做决定的能力。
And then with a good dollop of self-esteem, yeah, because the way that they expect and feel worthy of being treated in the world, yeah, that's what we're trying to build. Right, is that, that, that they go out there and they, they find relationships that, that deserve them. Yeah. And that they don't settle or think they should settle for less. Yeah. Right.
然后再加上一点健康的自尊心，是的，因为他们在世界上期望并觉得值得得到的对待方式，是的，这正是我们试图为他们建立的。对吧，就是让他们走出去，然后他们能够找到，值得拥有他们的关系的伴侣。是的。而且他们不会妥协，也不会觉得他们应该将就。是的。对吧？
Yeah. Well, Jayce, I can tell you in your case, you're lucky because she's got a great head on her shoulders and she's a great kid and she's going to be okay and you're going to be fine. Yeah. She's an awesome kid. Objectively. She's an awesome kid.
是的。好吧，杰斯，我可以告诉你，在你的情况下，你很幸运，因为她很有头脑，而且她是个好孩子，她会没事的，你也会没事的。是的。她是个极好的孩子。客观地讲。她是个极好的孩子。
Thank you. Yeah. And the camp goodbye is just warm up for the, the eventual college goodbye. That one is brutal. Yeah. I've done that twice. It wrecked me. Even the college tours, going, just driving around and seeing the places where they are
谢谢。是的。营地的告别只是最终大学告别的热身。那次告别太残酷了。是的。我经历过两次。把我整崩溃了。甚至大学参观，开车到处看看他们
going to be going, even two years before they go, I'm going to be a disaster. It's such a cliche. I realize that, but I mean, that college tour is a real kind of watershed memory builder, but the goodbye, because now they don't live with you anymore and they won't again. They might, but, you know, in some ways you hope they won't, but that's, yeah, I mean, it's just all these kinds of, you realize all these moments are, they're not going to be reclaimed. So you better be savoring them now at work, at home.
将要去的地方，甚至在他们去之前的两年，我都会变成一团糟。这太陈词滥调了。我意识到这一点，但我的意思是，大学参观确实是一种分水岭式的记忆塑造经历，但是告别，因为从那以后他们不再和你一起生活了，以后也不会了。也许会，但是，你知道，从某种程度上说，你希望他们不会，但那是，是的，我的意思是，所有这些时刻，你会意识到它们是无法挽回的。所以你最好现在就好好品味它们，无论是在工作中，还是在家里。
Hey's, hey's, you're lucky, your dad left when you were young because you didn't have to go through. He didn't, you spared him all this shit. He was, you know, now Sean, Sean, do you worry that you're going to gas and run out of, run out of steam right at the moment that you're an empty nester when it's like, it's time to get to work cause you don't have to worry about the kids back at home and, and being like, I worry about that. I worry about like working super hard while they're still at home and then running out
嘿，嘿，你很幸运，你父亲在你很小的时候就离开了，因为你不用经历这一切。他没有，他让你免受了所有这些狗屁倒灶的事。他曾，你知道的，现在肖恩，肖恩，你担不担心，就在你成为空巢老人、该卷起袖子大干一场的那个瞬间，你却突然没气力了、精疲力竭了，因为你再也不用担心家里的孩子，不用再去想——我担心这个。我担心在他们还在家的时候拼命工作，然后精疲力竭，结果家里除了我和阿曼达空无一人。我的意思是，如果我，我有成千上万种其他的恐惧，但油箱每天早上都感觉是满的。就像有人偷偷溜进来在夜里给它加满了一样。那种感觉，而且我知道我对此感到非常幸运。顺便说一句，肖恩，父亲的背景故事，如果说有什么作用的话，那就是它为威尔·阿奈特提供了喜剧金矿。我觉得他没有错过任何一个那样的梗。我太喜欢了。
of gas and now the house is empty except for me and Amanda. I mean, if I, I have a thousand other terrors, the gas tank feels full every morning. Like someone snuck in and refilled it at night. That's how, and that is, and I know I feel really lucky about that. And by the way, Sean, the, the dad backstory is, if anything, it's given Will Arnett comedy gold. I feel like he doesn't miss any of those pitches. I love it.
的燃气，现在家里除了我和阿曼达空无一人。我是说，如果我，我有成千上万的其他恐惧，每天早上燃气罐都感觉是满的。就像有人在夜里偷偷溜进来重新加满了一样。就是这样，而且那是，我知道对此我感到非常幸运。顺便说一句，肖恩，关于父亲的背景故事，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是它为威尔·阿奈特提供了喜剧素材。我觉得他没有错过任何那些投球。我喜欢这个。
He hits them all hard. And it's for like over a hundred episodes now. So on behalf of all listeners, thank you, dad, thank you for giving Will Arnett such honor. Thank you, man. You get to, you get to put a face to all those jokes. Oh no. I don't know if I want the face.
他把每一个梗都接得死死的。而且这已经持续了一百多集了。所以谨代表所有听众，谢谢爸爸，谢谢你为威尔·阿奈特提供了如此荣耀的素材。谢谢你，老兄。你可以，你可以为所有这些笑话对号入座了。哦，不。我不知道我想要这张脸。
I don't know if I can handle it. That's so funny. Yeah, by the way, anybody can make a joke on any subject, but try making a thousand jokes on the same subject. Good fucking luck. Bring it. Fucking bring it. Oh my God.
我不知道我能不能承受。太搞笑了。是的，顺便说一句，任何人都可以对任何主题开玩笑，但试着围绕同一个主题讲一千个笑话。祝你他妈的好运。放马过来吧。他妈的放马过来。天哪。
We do a bunch of stuff on food too, which Sean, I know you and I have gone round and round on, although you're naturally beautifully thin and narrow. Just like a little, look at a little hummingbird. I know why you're so in shape. Yeah, you do. You have the body of a Frenchman. Yeah. I, I don't know what, I mean.
我们在食物上也做了很多节目，肖恩，我知道你和我在这方面讨论过很多次，尽管你天生身材就非常苗条纤细。就像一只小小的，看那小蜂鸟。我知道为什么你身材这么好。是的，你知道。你有着法国人的身材。是的。我，我不知道，我的意思是。
Yes. Just take it. I've heard these things. I'll take it. Thank you. You and Ryan. But, but no, speaking of Ryan, I literally. What's, what's craft service look like on a set with you and Ryan and the caterers?
是的。接受吧。我听说过这些。我接受。谢谢你。你和瑞安。但是，但是不，说到瑞安，我 literalmente。你和瑞安以及餐饮服务团队在片场的伙食是什么样的？
Is there's a salad bar set up every day, right? I'm not big on salad, but I do get super bitchy if I don't eat protein every three hours. I have learned this about myself. So this is where I go for the douche award. You and me are neck and neck now, Will, because one of, one of the, one of the job duties if whoever's my assistant on a movie is you got to get protein in my body every three hours or the whole crew is going to pay the price. Is this plant protein?
是不是每天都有一份沙拉吧？我对沙拉不太感冒，但如果每隔三小时不吃蛋白质，我就会变得超级刻薄。我已经摸清了自己这一点。所以这就是我竞争混蛋奖的地方。你和我现在不相上下了，威尔，因为其中一个，无论谁是我的电影助理，你的工作职责之一就是每隔三小时把蛋白质送到我嘴里，否则整个剧组都要付出代价。这是植物蛋白吗？
It's plant protein. Isn't it? No. It's like, you know, the Ryan Hugh diet. It's like the chicken, the boring chicken breast, maybe the sashimi, it's like, go ahead. Go ahead, Will. I know.
是植物蛋白。难道不是吗？不是。就像，你知道的，瑞安·休伊特饮食。就像鸡胸肉，无聊的鸡胸肉，也许还有刺身，来吧。来吧，威尔。我知道。
Oh, he doesn't know about. Yeah. This is on the tour. Okay. Which was, which was. We don't want to. We don't want to, we don't want to ruin the job. No, no, no.
哦，他不知道关于。好吧。这在巡演上。好吧，这，这是。我们不想。我们不想，我们不想，我们不想毁了这份工作。不，不，不。
You will not ruin it. It's got four or five uses in it. Guys, uh, you know, I was going to make something else, but I got, I got Japanese food instead. Sashimi. It's a joke. Yeah. But it's an evergreen.
你不会毁了它的。它里面有四五种用法。伙计们，呃，你知道，我本来打算做点别的，但我拿到了，我换成了日本料理。刺身。是个笑话。是的。但这是一个常青梗。
I feel like that one's an evergreen. Like, I feel like I've heard them laugh at that joke on this show before. Yeah. And it's still landing. It's still landing. But wait, do you ever eat like crap food? Do you ever like? I love sugar.
我觉得那个梗是个常青梗。就像，我觉得我以前在这档节目里听过他们笑过那个笑话。是的。而且它依然很有笑果。依然很有笑果。但是等等，你吃过垃圾食品吗？你吃过吗？我喜欢糖。
And if I start, I'm like, if I had a bag of, uh, like caramel corn right now, I would finish it. Like it's my job. Yeah. And like, if I'm, when I'm in an airport, especially if I'm alone and I'll get like one of the, you know, the mega size M&Ms with peanut butter in it, forget it. What is your number one? Well, I want to go around the horn because I don't actually know this.
如果我开始吃，就像我如果现在有一袋，呃，比如焦糖爆米花，我会把它吃完。就像这是我的工作一样。是的。而且，如果我在机场，特别是如果我独自一人，我会买那种，你知道的，里面有花生酱的超大号M&M巧克力豆，别提了。你最喜欢的是什么？好吧，我想轮流问一圈，因为我其实并不知道这个。
What's everybody's number one dessert? If you could have only one, like your top, the list go dessert ice cream. It's always hang on. It's not your turn. Oh, I thought you pointed at me. What the God, not only you can't even wait, you can't wait to get it out and you can't wait to get it in. I mean, Jesus.
每个人的头号甜点是什么？如果你只能选一种，比如你的首选甜点，冰淇淋。总是等等。还没轮到你。哦，我还以为你指着我呢。天哪，不仅你甚至等不及，你等不及把它拿出来，你等不及把它塞进去。我的意思是，天哪。
I'm partial to a creme brulee. I like, I like a good creme brulee, but again, I'm not like a snappy top with, I like a little crunch shop. I like to work through the crunchy surface to get to the mushy innards. Yeah. That's my go to. He gets that real methi lighter when they, yes, even better if they do it at the table. So I see someone working.
我比较喜欢焦糖布丁。我喜欢，我喜欢一个好的焦糖布丁，但话说回来，我不是那种喜欢一口咬碎的，我喜欢有点脆壳的。我喜欢敲碎脆脆的表面去吃到里面软绵绵的内心。是的。那是我的最爱。他喜欢用那种真正的喷枪，是的，如果他们能在桌边现场做那就更好了。所以我也看到有人在忙活。
Sean's still dying from, can't wait to get it out and you can't wait to shove it in. How many times has Scottie said that to you? Wait, Bateman, go. Yeah. You're not a big dessert guy either. I can't even imagine you eating dessert. I do. You want to know how douchey and terrible is.
肖恩还在因为“等不及把它拿出来，你等不及把它塞进去”这句话笑得不行。斯科蒂对你说过多少次这话了？等等，巴特曼，你说。是的。你也不是个超级甜点控。我甚至无法想象你吃甜点的样子。我吃啊。你想知道我有多混蛋、多可怕吗。
I do like carbolite. That's the frozen yogurt with no sugar, no fat, no dairy. I have no idea what it is, but it's cold and it's colorful and you can eat it with a spoon. It's so, by the way, that's so fucking lame. One of the first times Jason and I, like over 20 years ago, he was like so excited and he goes right down on Crescent Heights and Beverly. Remember that place in the fucking mall? Yeah, sure.
我确实喜欢无糖低脂冰冻酸奶。那是没有糖、没有脂肪、没有乳制品的老酸奶。我不知道那是什么东西，但它是凉的，五颜六色的，你可以用勺子挖着吃。顺便说一句，这太他妈逊了。我和杰森第一次见面时，大约20年前，他当时兴奋得不得了，他说就在克雷森特海茨和贝弗利。还记得那个破商场里的那个地方吗？对，当然。
And you were like, well, let's go get the fro yo fro fro go go or whatever the fuck you called it. And it was like, it was like plastic. Yeah. He's like, isn't this great? And it's nothing. Right? And I'm like, no, this is fucking disgusting.
然后你说，好吧，我们去吃那个fro-yo（冷冻酸奶）还是什么他妈的叫法。这感觉就像塑料一样。是的。他说，这不是很棒吗？而这根本什么都不是。对吧？而我说，不，这太他妈恶心了。
No, it's disgusting. Listen, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not above admitting, I love dessert and I love ice cream like Sean. I like Hayes. Sean Levy, what, you're in Hungary right now. Tell us what do you do in your free time there? Tell us like any kind of crazy stories about the, I wish I had crazy stories. But I did have, I did, no, I definitely fought the blues here a bit.
不，这太恶心了。听着，我不是，我不是，我不会羞于承认，我喜欢甜点，我像肖恩一样喜欢冰淇淋。我喜欢海斯。肖恩·利维，什么，你现在在匈牙利。告诉我们在那里你闲暇时都做些什么？给我们讲讲任何关于，我希望我能有什么疯狂的故事。但我确实有，我没有，我在这里确实有点对抗忧郁情绪。
I have to admit, like it's just, it's a long haul. I've been alone for most of it. I've had so much goulash and it is as it sounds, right? Like that's just kind of, that should be an adjective for how it's been for fun. Yeah. You're pretty East there in Hungary. Yes. Eastern European is a different look.
我必须承认，就像这是一段漫长的旅程。我大部分时间都是一个人呆着。我吃了很多古洛什汤，它听起来就是那样，对吧？就像那是对这段旅程有多好的一种讽刺。是的。你在匈牙利相当靠东的地方。是的。东欧的风格确实不一样。
There's a palette there, literally that is a little bit grayer and. And you feel the history. You feel centuries of occupation and you, yeah, so, but I did. So I finally rose, wait, I am a happy person. Why am I not happy? I got to go places on the weekend. So I went to Berlin and there I did have a wild weekend. I did exactly what you imagine in your head.
那里有一种色调，literally 就是稍微偏灰一点，而且。你能感受到历史。你能感受到几个世纪的占领，你，是的，所以，但我做了。所以我终于振作起来，等等，我是一个快乐的人。为什么我不快乐？我周末得去四处走走。所以我去了柏林，在那里我确实度过了一个疯狂的周末。我做了你脑海中想象的那种事。
You would do. And like age inappropriate. I was with my brother, we went to a club till 4.30 a.m., like that, that was the song. Yes. Exactly. Right. That's weird. The clubs in Berlin.
你会做的。而且极其不符合年龄。我和我兄弟一起，我们去了一个俱乐部直到凌晨4点半，就像那样，那就是这首歌。是的。完全正确。这很奇怪。柏林的俱乐部。
I mean, what I kind of noted, like there's no aggressive kind of creepy vibe is just everyone is actually there to listen to that beat, the chasing and do it this mouth freakishly well by the way. And just dead. I started as a beatboxer. I love, I love Berlin. I'm with you. I love Berlin.
我的意思是，我注意到的一点是，那里没有什么咄咄逼人的诡异氛围，每个人其实都只是为了去听那种节拍，追逐并把这个嘴巴玩得怪异般的好，顺便说一句。然后就死寂了。我一开始是个节奏口技表演者。我喜欢，我喜欢柏林。我和你一样。我喜欢柏林。
I think it's one of the great cities. It's so much fun. Yeah. Great restaurants. How much longer? How much longer do you have there, Sean? One day. Truly?
我认为它是伟大的城市之一。太有趣了。是的。很棒的餐厅。还要多久？你在那儿还要待多久，肖恩？一天。真的吗？
This is literally one day more guys. Wow. I'm like, I'm flying through this because I have my last day of shooting tomorrow and then we moved to France for the final two weeks of shooting there in France and then back home. Where in France? Are you going to be in Paris? Are you in the countryside?
这简直literally 就只剩最后一天了，伙计们。哇。我的进度像飞一样，因为我明天有最后一天的拍摄，然后我们要搬到那里的法国，进行最后两周的拍摄，然后就回家。在法国哪里？你们要去巴黎吗？你们在乡下吗？
No, we're in the country. We're in the town where the novel is set called Semelo, which is right in Brittany on the coast. It's the westernmost coast of France. Beautiful. So we're shooting there. It's beautiful. These huge ramparts in the ocean, massive beach and it's where this actual event happened, where the Germans occupied it and the Americans came over and they bombed the shit out of
不，我们在乡下。我们在小说背景里那个叫圣马洛的小镇，它就在布列塔尼的海岸上。那是法国最西端的海岸。很美。所以我们在那里拍摄。非常美丽。那里有巨大的海防工事拍打着海洋，巨大的海滩，这就是实际事件发生的地方，德国人占领了那里，然后美国人赶来，把整个小镇轰炸得稀巴烂
the town in order to liberate it. And that's kind of the part of the story that we're shooting. Oh, that's awesome. Sean, we have taken up way too much of your time. I love it. Thank you so much for delighting us. You are. You're absolutely delight.
为了解放它。而这正是我们正在拍摄的那部分故事。哦，太棒了。肖恩，我们占用了你太多时间了。我太喜欢了。非常感谢你带给我们的快乐。你真的是。你绝对是个开心果。
In every way. You've delighted us with your art, like I said, and you've delighted us with your presence here today and your character and your perspective. Yeah. And you're just a great guy and so happy for you. And you seem so happy legitimately, which is all your success and Sean is always a great hang on or off work. Uh, I mean, buddy, uh, more, please.
各方面都是。就像我说的，你用你的艺术给我们带来了快乐，你今天用你的存在、你的性格和你的视角给我们带来了快乐。是的。而且你真的是个大好人，为你感到由衷的高兴。你看上去真的很幸福，这是你所有的成功应得的，而且肖恩无论在工作还是生活中都总是那么好相处。呃，我的意思是，老兄，呃，再来点，求你了。
Lots, lots more. Well, I, I've loved chatting with you guys and I love your show. I'm such a fan and hopefully I can tell sweet and I didn't push you hard and blow the whole thing. No, you're great. You're great. You were incredible. Truly.
多多益善。好吧，我，我跟你们聊天非常开心，我也很喜欢你们的节目。我是你们的超级粉丝，希望我能说，太棒了，我没有逼得太紧而把整件事搞砸。不，你很棒。你很棒。你太不可思议了。真的。
Thank you for having me, fellas. Excellent. Thank you. I miss you, Sean, a bunch, buddy. Hurry home. All right. Bye guys. Love you, pal.
谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。太棒了。谢谢。肖恩，我很想你，老兄。快点回家吧。好了。再见，伙计们。爱你们，老兄。
Bye, buddy. Bye, buddy. Bye, bye. That guy, I can't, Sean Laney is just one of my favorite people in the whole world. You know, I try to quit him emotionally and spiritually, you know, because he doesn't live here anymore. And he does. He literally got 17 projects in development.
再见，老兄。再见，老兄。再见，再见。那个家伙，我真是，肖恩·利维简直是我全世界最喜欢的人之一。你知道的，我试图在情感上和精神上“开除”他，你知道的，因为他不再住在这里了。但他确实住这儿。他居然有17个正在开发的项目。
It's crazy. I know. When Hayes, you were saying like his, his attitude and his energy is so sort of infectious. And yeah, it is, it's infectious and it's so buoyant and upbeat and kind of, you know, like I can imagine what that must be like on a set with a personality like that that's just always supportive. Never, it's never like, you know, I don't know if that really worked, you know, kind of like attitude, you know, you don't want to be around that.
太疯狂了。我知道。当海斯，你之前说他的，他的态度和他的能量是如此具有感染力，是的，确实如此，它具有感染力，而且如此充满活力、积极向上，而且，你知道的，就像我可以想象在片场面对这样一种性格会是什么样，永远支持你，从来不是那种，你知道的，我不知道这到底行不行，你知道，那种态度，你知道的，你可不想跟那种人待在一起。
Let's go again and suck less. Yeah. He does never, you'll never hear that from him. No, he's, he's, he's happy and capable. Like that's like a great combo. Is a great combo. That's a really, yeah. I love all the stuff in the middle about like all, when I was, I joked around, I was like,
让我们再来一次，少出点洋相。是的。他从来没有，你永远不会从他嘴里听到那种话。不，他，他，他既快乐又有能力。就像这简直是个绝佳的组合。是个绝佳的组合。这真的，是的。我喜欢中间关于所有这些的讨论，就像，当我开玩笑说，
this is the best therapy session because he's, and even you will were like, it's down, now is the time. I love that to just do what you want to do. Like the only person holding you back is you, that all that kind of stuff. It's one thing to know it. I mean, to, to, to hear it, but you have to incorporate it. It's the next. It's the hardest.
这是最好的心理治疗，因为他，甚至连你威尔也说，时机就是现在，现在就是时候。我太喜欢这种态度了，去做你想做的事吧。唯一阻挡你的人就是你自己，所有这些乱七八糟的。知道是一回事。我的意思是，听到是一回事，但你必须把它融入生活中。那是下一步。那是人类最难的。
One of the great things that we joked a lot about my, my dumb vacation, which was, it should be noted the first vacation since before COVID. Yeah. I'm glad you did that for yourself. You and Alessandra deserved that. Yeah. And we, you know, it's been a crazy two years and the baby and he was born prematurely and all the stuff, just all the stress and we kind of let it all go.
我们经常拿我那次愚蠢的假期开玩笑，这件美妙的事应该指出的是，这是我自新冠疫情爆发以来度过的第一个假期。是的。我很高兴你为自己做了这件事。你和亚历桑德拉应得的。是的。而且我们，你知道的，这过去两年太疯狂了，还有宝宝，他是早产儿，等等各种事情，压力太大了，我们只是把这一切都释放了。
We were down there. You guys haven't been just the two of you for like ever since January, since before COVID. And again, I know that's like, oh, poor boohoo. There's a lot of people who were like, I've never fucking been away. So any couple needs to have just one on one time. Yeah. And I will say when the great things was, we were, we talked a lot about it and I was
我们在那里。你们两个已经有多久没有只有彼此二人世界了，大概自一月以来，自新冠疫情之前以来。再说一次，我知道这听起来像是，哦，真可怜，太惨了。有很多人会说，我他妈从来没有离开过。所以任何伴侣都需要有纯粹的二人世界时间。是的。我必须说，最棒的事情之一就是，我们对此进行了很多讨论，我当时就说，
like, look, it is fucking now life is happening and you got to like get out into it and, and start speaking up. I want to go back to the things that you guys, that you guys said, no more, no more dinners and restaurant. I like to go out to dinner and restaurant still. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we just did it as a family last night and a man and I said this morning, it's like,
听着，生活他妈的现在就在发生，你必须走出去，然后开始大声说出来。我想回到你们刚才说的那些事情上，你们说的，再也不去餐馆吃晚饭了。我其实还是喜欢去餐厅吃晚饭的。是的。是的。好吧，我们昨晚才全家一起去吃过，阿曼达和我在今天早上说，这就像是，
let's just say, I literally referenced you, Will. I said to a man, I said, let's, let's do it. Arnett's family was like, no one in, no one out on Sunday. Like just any day of the week, it's nice to just commit to just having that bond or just taking a walk. Yeah. And by the way, Alex Arnett, my mom will be so happy to hear that Sunday night, nobody in, nobody out is still alive.
让我们这么做吧，我literally 向你致敬了，威尔。我对阿曼达说，我说，让我们照做吧。阿奈特一家就像是，周日任何人都不准出门，任何人都不准进来。就像一周中的任何一天，能承诺仅仅拥有那种陪伴，或者只是去散散步，都非常美好。是的。顺便说一句，亚历克斯·阿奈特，我妈妈听到周日晚上“任何人都不准进来，任何人都不准出门”这个规矩依然在执行，一定会非常高兴的。
It's great. Yeah. It is great. It's so important to have those moments. And we have, we all have a lot of, look, we, you guys are my family. You guys are my extended family too, and, but we need those moments with our kids and our significant other where we sit down and we're just kind of quiet with each other. Yeah.
太棒了。是的。这太棒了。拥有那些时刻太重要了。我们都有很多，听着，你们是我的家人。你们也是我的大家庭，但是我们需要那些与孩子们和另一半在一起的时刻，我们坐在一起，彼此之间只是静静地陪伴。是的。
Super important. My dad just lived by that. Did he? Yeah. Who was, who were the people he was doing it with? Yeah. They were folks that didn't mind the long drive. No one in, no one out.
超级重要。我爸爸就是奉行这一套的。是吗？是的。他都是跟什么人一起这么做的？是的。都是些不介意开长途车的人。谁也不准进，谁也不准出。
Locked the door. Did you think he just drove until he ran out of gas or did he have a destination? Like what was that? I'm not pumping at the next station. You in the back. What was your name again? You're going to do it. He loved hitchhikers.
锁上门。你觉得他只是开车直到汽油耗尽，还是他有目的地？那到底是怎么回事？我才不在下一个加油站加油呢。坐在后排的那个。你叫什么名字来着？你得照做。他超爱搭车的人。
He sure did. Oh, but you know what? He was nice to, the way he left was nice. He didn't, it wasn't a long like, you know, thing like, well, it was just a really quick bike, nice, nice, nice, Sean, smart, smart, smart less is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco and Michael Granteri smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
他确实这么做了。哦，但你知道吗？他很好，他离开的方式很好。他没有，这不是那种长篇大论的，你知道的，就只是一次非常快的骑行，很好，很好，很好，肖恩，聪明的，聪明的，聪明的 Less 是由罗布·阿尔姆约尔夫、贝内特·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机和手工制作的 Smart Loss。我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅 Wondry Plus 提前收听并免广告
in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在苹果播客或 Wondry 应用上。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。